in a world of powerful computers and
essential software how important can a
paper and pen really be to a game
designer well the creators of ballpoint
universe infinite have found great value
in those basic tools crafting a surreal
world out of ballpoint ink strokes you
first interact with the game in its over
world where your own hand-drawn
character looks like a doodle of a
radish atop a tortilla chip a top two
toothpicks you move left and right with
a half hazardous that seems appropriate
given how weird your own character looks
and how weird his world is this
clumsiness isn't a big issue until
you're forced to navigate tight
platforms and moving obstacles doing so
is almost impossible using the default
Mouse only control scheme so be sure to
plug in a controller using a gamepad
isn't a magic solution to the movements
general imprecision but it alleviates
the problem enough to allow you to focus
on this fantastical place you interact
with a cigar-chomping boots a television
wearing a ball cap a floating cycloptic
octopus and many more freaks of nature
and you do so in a land that looks like
the mad marvelous scribbles of a pen
wielding maniac I wouldn't call
ballpoint universe beautiful exactly but
it's impossible to look away from this
wondrous place
most of the time ballpoint universe
infinite plays like a side-scrolling
shooter the slight clumsiness of the
platforming is also evident in the
shooting but space missions rarely
require great precision instead they're
more like bizarre laboratories where you
try out different ship configurations
and discover the most efficient methods
of killing your ships customizable slots
allow you to outfit all sorts of
upgradable guns shields and swords yes
indeed your craft supports melee weapons
that slice up nearby attackers
automatically when they draw near melee
weapons have different attack ranges and
arcs and much of the combats fun comes
from discovering just how closely you
can approach eral before your space
sword swipes it away the blobs of ink
that annihilated foes leave behind
further prompt you to fly directly into
danger ink is ballpoint universe's
currency and most of it will evaporate
away if you don't spin and suck it up a
variety of weapons is one of the game's
best assets there's enough diversity
among the various weapons in terms of
range power and behavior that missions
rarely feel stale
enemies look as fanciful as the world
does one boss is Elizabethan royalty
with a ruffled collar and a pointy hat
who looks like he was cut from a playing
card before you can purchase more
powerful weaponry facing this and other
bullet stoking behemoths can be tedious
fortunately the tedium is short-lived
most often you're weaving in and out of
enemy fire and swooping towards angels
of death to down them with a chain sword
ultimately you'll have earned enough ink
to power quite a ways through the game's
infinite mode and its ceaseless waves of
drifting deviants ballpoint universe
infinite doesn't feature notably tight
battles or precise platforming but its
imaginative visuals quirky characters
and satisfying customization options
keep you invested and entertained I've
never visited a universe quite like this
one and it's hard not to be enamored by
its exuberance
you